sur place maintenant à l'opéra rock donc
au palais des congrès starmania france
page vous êtes sur place oui et france
gall joue dans starmania l'un personnage
que je suis un peu gâché une personne
qui interviewe des gens et qui en fait
des stades mais elle en fait des stars
tandis que moi j'interviens déjà je ne
savais pas que c'était un métier où on
prenait autant de risques parce qu'elle
est interviewé un terroriste par exemple
c'est prend des risques dans la pièce
vous interviewer un terroriste et même
vous êtes presque enlevait par lui alors
si on dévoile l'action oui oui et c'est
vous qui chantez le thème de la pièce
qui s car mania est le thème non je
chante le thème de mon émission de
télévision qui s'appelle starmania
il ya une chanson il ya une chanson pour
l'émission et je la chante toujours je
fais quand je fais mon show
régulièrement je commence par chanter
cette chanson là qu'est la chanson de
tania vous pourriez leïla chante et on
pourra peut-être la fendre en chef eric
à l'accord et pendant ce temps diane
dufresne c'est la première fois que vous
jouez un spectacle que vous n'avez pas
écrit mais c'est à dire que j'ai jamais
eu en fait de vraiment de metteur en
scène c'est une expérience pour moi de
travailler avec eux
savon couru à la folie
23 28
toi
sama samaja pubblico copains chaman
arraï à damas ce qu'est ce qui dans le
silence car toi
ce soit comme on se marre
et dans 10 à 7
da costa
des barrières carte de tous
[ __ ]
cet attentat
tout ce qui m'arrive
mon métier me moucher combien qui
sécurise pas quand tu vas tramontane
commis pourquoi
à tous
voilà on va laisser starmania et la
répétition se poursuivre il ya encore
quelques petits problèmes que vous
l'avez constaté on se retrouve dans
trois minutes pour notre page spéciale
consacrée à la médecine a tout de suite